got two equations here we want to find
out where these lines cross and the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
graph them and we're gonna find the
common point of intersection so this
equation you can see is already in the
slope-intercept form the y equals MX
plus B form so all we have to do is
graph the y-intercept and the slope so
let's that do that over here we've got
one two three four five six seven
negative eight okay so it crosses right
there the slope is two so up 2 over 1 up
2 over 1 up 2 over 1 okay and so on okay
so there's our line the second line is
in the standard form so what we're going
to do here is we're going to set X to 0
solve for the y intercept so you can see
y equals 3 and then if we set Y to 0 you
can see x equals 4 when we divide by 3
so that's going to be 1 2 3 4 ok those
are our two lines now it looks like
they're crossing somewhere right around
here at 3 and 1/2 comma 1/2 and this is
the downside to the graphing method is
that if your lines a little bit off your
point of intersection is going to be a
little bit off and so if you're doing a
problem like this what you're going to
want to do is take that point that you
think is the common point of
intersection go ahead and put it back in
and make sure that it satisfies both
equations